let's bring in Danny Ainge the Celtics
GM you know speaking of the Dodgers
going 43 and 7 I was wondering about
your baseball career as you go back best
best pitcher you ever faced with who oh
I would say Jeff Morris gave me the most
problems why he he had a split finger in
those days that was fairly new to the
league and he do about 95 miles an hour
but that split finger got me but I had
you know I had a game or two where I got
a couple of hits off but Nolan Ryan and
he was pretty special too but I would
say Jack Morris that's pretty good
though you got a couple of knocks off
Nolan Ryan did he strike you out oh yeah
I meant to but what was that moment that
crystallisation where you go I can't
play I don't want to play baseball
anymore
Oh Dan I don't think that ever happened
I loved baseball you know I was a
youngster I didn't really give it much
of a shot because I was always playing
it during in between my basketball
season in college and but I didn't
really ever I felt like I could make it
in baseball and it was just more I don't
think I had I've been drafted by the
Lakers of the Celtics that I would have
gone to the NBA and I probably would
have stayed in baseball to career home
runs by the way Danny spent three
seasons with the Toronto Blue Jays those
two home runs came off of I know one
came off of Joe Decker I don't remember
the second Danny you only hit doing I
know I know it it's not that many to
remember no I don't really that they
weren't really that memorable all right
let me talk to you about the offseason
explain to me how it works where you and
Philadelphia get together to have this
trade but who calls who first to
initiate Philadelphia called us to
initiate I think but I'm not sure I mean
at the time of the draft Daniel we're
talking to everybody myself and guys on
my staff were talking to see if there's
just any interest and moving
around moving up moving down obviously
we could only move down and at the same
time we're evaluating all the kids we're
getting a man we're interviewing them
were you know watching them do workouts
and just having conversation about all
the different possibilities so I can't
actually remember who initiated the
calls but it's pretty common that you
have conversation with everybody you
know in that area how do you know when
somebody's telling you the truth you
don't but it doesn't matter I mean you
just know what you want to do and what
you're trying to accomplish in it
doesn't matter who's telling the truth
you just try to make the best deal for
your team can you get too young too
young for to be a general no no no no
too happy thinking a team be too young
yeah to compete like are you too young
yeah absolutely I think it's I think
it's not hard for young players to
contribute to good teams I mean we've
seen that time and time again throughout
our history in the NBA but you can have
too many young players for sure it's
tough for a group of young players to
lead a team to have a lot of wins but um
but you can have some you can have a
couple guys that can contribute a young
age why do you think Paul George is in
an Oklahoma City uniform I don't know I
think I think that was a difficult
situation where you know he was
expressing interest in going or at least
publicly going to the west
to when his free agent here was up put
some pressure on Indiana to try to get
something in return for him and Oklahoma
City made the offer that enticed Indiana
more than anybody else but do you think
that it played into the fact that you
don't want to keep him in the East where
he comes back to haunt you
you know that that I felt like they took
a lesser deal to go keep you know
descending west and keep him in the
Eastern Conference
is that fair assessment um I don't know
you would have to ask them them that you
know everybody sees these deals in
different in different ways but did you
have a bed really like the players they
got did you give a better deal than that
you know that's a matter of opinion you
know in everybody else's opinion doesn't
matter the only one that matters is
Indiana's opinion where who the best
deals was how did the Cavs affect what
you do or do that it doesn't know
nothing nothing it doesn't matter I mean
we're we have our own problems and our
own challenges and trying to find put
players together they can they can win
and compete in the league today is very
difficult and I mean obviously we're
competing against to try to get the same
players that everybody wants in the
league but other than that we're not
reacting to things that they're doing
right now what we hear they have a great
team I mean haven't when you have LeBron
James on your team when you you've got
to be you got to find some players that
can compete against him and that's tough
to do he's been the best player in the
league for the last five or six years if
I said let's match the bronze best
season against Birds best season I think
bird at 30 or 31 almost averaged a
triple-double you remember that season
I'm going to guess right right
would you uh is it similar you know
they're just different um LeBron is you
know he's a cross between you know
Michael and magic I mean he's such a
fantastic passer like magic was he's so
strong like magic was he's more athletic
but then he has this ability to score
you know what the Brawn is is very very
special and I you know I said this all
the time when the players asked me it
was better I mean I think Kareem and bad
LeBron those guys are all worthy of
being considered the best players of all
time but I think that and Bill Russell
but I think that Larry what he was so
special at is is so hard to find he was
so great such a great competitor but
also such a great finisher of games the
guy played with amazing confidence you
know there's a lot of games that we
played against LeBron over the years
where he's just been unguardable and you
just can't guard him and he you just tip
your hat and say he's just so special
but there are other games where he know
he struggles with his outside shooting
and you know and what we were able to
win and he doesn't play with that same
sort of competence with his shot but you
know his shots getting better and better
and better as he ages and the more that
shot goes in the more unguardable he
just becomes yeah he just recently
passed Byrd on my list of the old-time
AI Reggie Miller and I were talking
about it and Reggie said I love Larry
but you know LeBron just he moved past
Larry and in which I understand and I'm
sure Larry would agree with that but I
wonder Larry in today's generation
shooting the three how much different he
would have been he was a great shooter I
mean Larry didn't shoot the threes it
was a different year like I tried to get
Larry to shoot more threes and you know
he wouldn't I mean our guys just grew up
we grew up you know field goal
percentage was was important now in true
shooting percentage and scoring
efficiencies important in the
three-point line is utilized more and
more and it was evolving on none of us
played with the three-point line in high
school or college so yeah there's no
doubt I mean with the three-point line
and if Larry had utilized the
three-point line more he coming into the
game today after playing it in high
school in college and coming into the
NBA be one of the great shooters of all
time Gordon Hayward the pitch that you
had
involved were you with obviously
involved but did you who seals the deal
in that situation with a word well I
mean I think that there's a lot of
factors I think our players sealed the
deal our coaching staff sealed the deal
the city Boston our tradition had an
impact I think that more than anything
Gordon really wants to win is the
impression that I got from him and about
the coach Stevens did a fantastic job of
presenting to Gordon
a pathway to winning how he would be
utilized in our system and with our
players and I think that ultimately I
think he saw that pathway
to winning and success better in Boston
than he did in other places are you a
better team than Cleveland there I don't
know I mean first of all the summer and
the off seasons not over there's still
time and there's a lot of factors there
but you know we have some new guys and
they haven't done anything yet
we just had an off season but we've
acquired some players that we like and
you know that's a question maybe I can
answer in November or December but
certainly can't answer it now Danny is
obviously the Celtics GM president
Abascal operations but his son Tanner
he's helping his election campaign in
Utah
so he's come up with a unique
fundraising opportunity that's tonight
admission is free give me some details
on this what do I get for $25 showing up
here for this campaign fund well you get
a chance to dunk me and I know there's a
lot of Utah fans that are not happy with
me right now and so yeah you get a
chance to dunk me in that in the tank
it's a you know it's at fort 14:26 east
750 north in Orem Utah it's seven
o'clock tonight
my son tanner is an amazing young man
he's with a great work ethic he has
great experience
not necessarily in politics but in the
financial world in the healthcare world
he's been a practicing attorney he's
very smart very educated and driven and
I think you'd be an amazing candidate
sometimes I wonder why do people want to
get in politics and he has so many
opportunities outside of the political
field but he really wants to be make a
difference and I think he can so yeah
we're a hundred percent behind him give
me that address again at seven o'clock
tonight $25 you show up you'll be in a
dunk tank and you can fire away 14 14 26
East 750 north and ormita
by the way John Montague was the other
pitcher who gave up a home run to you oh
ok I remember that now I could answer
that question but was the last time that
I saw you was that in we played golf
with Marlee in Phoenix yeah that was
like 2002
yeah what were you doing then you were
still playing were you know I think I
had I think I was doing television I
think I was in year world or up to be
here and I was working for tea during
NBA games but then a year later I got
this job but how nervous is I know your
competitor but you go from that to being
a GM like how naive were you back then
when you look back at that that time um
I don't think I was naive I think I had
a pretty good feel because I had coached
for four years in Phoenix and I played I
was involved a lot with Bryan Colangelo
as a young general manager Jerry
Colangelo who's a fantastic owner they
involved me a great deal in the
personnel decisions and I was in those
conversations and so I felt I felt like
I knew what I was getting into and I've
enjoyed being in Boston we have great
ownership in Boston as well and I've had
a great partnership with them and that's
that's the whole key is if you can get
your coaching staff and
owners and your general managers on the
same page it's a fun job do you got a
Larry Bird story for us before we let
you go what I haven't heard oh man I got
so many Larry Bird stories you know like
the greatest thing about Larry I mean
every time I just think of Larry I just
think is of the extreme competence of
Larry you know he I always thought I was
competent you know I always thought
Kevin McHale was confident but Larry
just had a different level but he would
tell guy he was going to shoot in their
face like I'm gonna do this I was always
amazed that you know guys would say yeah
Larry would say it's like Xavier
McDaniel you know he told me he's going
to shoot a jumper right in my face right
there ya know I remember that whole
story vividly but I there was a there
was a lesser told story where he made a
bet with the trainer of the New York
Knicks and before the game we were out
shooting three Larry and I were shooting
threes before the game and Larry he said
hey I bet you 20 bucks you can't Bank
one in like that in the game and Larry
goes you're on and so the game proceeds
and we're behind by or we get ahead by
about 20 points the fourth quarter our
bench comes in the game and all of a
sudden you know the Knicks are starting
to creep back in the game but it still
feels like we have the game under
control and the trainer for the next
looks down at me and you know says like
get a get Larry his attention he sends
him the sign like you owe me 20 bucks
you never banked in a three pointer and
Larry goes it crap I can't believe I
forgot that you know and he was and so
sure enough the game gets down to seven
points I think it was and Casey Jones
puts the starters back in the game and
within the first two or three
possessions Larry gets a shot on the
corner and banks in a 3-pointer at that
stage of the game I mean with the close
game
I could see it was a 20-point lead but I
mean I'll never mean I got so many of
the confidence stories like that but
that's just
he cared more about that 20 bucks
Bethenny oh yeah he was so cheap I could
just imagine I didn't want to owe him
$20 you know yeah yeah hey good luck
with Tanner great to talk to you again
Danny Congrats on the success there in
Boston and hopefully we'll dig up again
Dan you've made pretty good for yourself
these last 15 years since I last saw you
yeah you said that I was basically done
my career was over and I said I gotta
prove you wrong you motivated I was only
that was only your golf you're right
about that or career you but it Marley
was the one who was great in golf we we
weren't right dan dan like he didn't
have a job no just shoot a couple of
three-pointers occasionally try to guard
Jordan and get a good Sun Tan that's all
Marley did his little life right hey
he's done a great job of coaching down
in Arizona oh he may have a that may be
his niche there he's done a fantastic
job down there yeah that atmosphere is
some of the best atmosphere in college
basketball it's great to catch up
whether you have fun tonight with the
dunk tank and good luck to Tanner Thank
You Danny
all right thanks Dan that's a Danny
Ainge the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience